energy rapporte 23 milliards sur le
budget de l'état
à regarder de plus près elles sont loin
de serre vise à mettre en place une
fiscalité écologique bien loin de là il
y a même des désengagements dans ce
domaine elles servent plutôt à boucher
les trous des cadeaux fiscaux donnés
dans la première année du quinquennat
aux plus riches d'entre nous je croyais
monsieur le sénateur que dans votre
sensibilité politique comme dans la
mienne comme dans beaucoup sur ces bancs
du sénat de l'assemblée nationale 2
des français des français qui vous ont
élus que vous ont élu avec les élus
locaux de france partout en france était
pour agir contre le dérèglement
climatique
quand on a dit qu'il fallait agir pour
le climat tout le monde était d'accord
pour dire qu'il fallait une fiscalité
écologique
et lorsque nous la mettons en oeuvre
vous dites je reprends vos mots monsieur
le sénateur ce que vous n'avez pas
parler à la légère
vous avez dit c'est violent et c'est du
poison ou en décompte des mots que vous
utilisez et le cleee la dérèglement
climatique lui vous trouvez qu'il n'est
ni violent ni un poison pour les
françaises et les français et toutes
celles et tous ceux qui en subissent
directement les conséquences
je ne sais pas parce qu'on peint un
matraquage fiscal en verre qu'il devient
écologistes c'est un matraquage fiscal
et
nous n'avons pas de leçons à recevoir
concernant l'écologie quand vous
regardez sur ces 23 milliards d'euros ce
qui va à la transition écologique
vous vous rendez compte qu'il n'ya pas
grand chose
monsieur le premier ministre votre plan
libéral est en contradiction totale avec
les besoins de notre société
quand admettrez vous que la casse du
service public de ceux qui ne se
marchandises pare brise le trait d'union
la solidarité sociale territoriale au
sein de notre république
monsieur le premier ministre votre voie
est sans issue
l approche d'ailleurs sur l'avenir de
notre pays mais aussi de l'europe
nous attendons de votre part un sursaut
républicain pour stopper la saignée que
vous imposez aux services publics
nationaux et locaux allez vous y mettre
fin
madame la sénatrice vécu karman quelques
mots pour répondre peut-être à deux de
vos interrogations d'abord pour
m'associer aux mots du président du
sénat qui salue et votre capacité à
rejoindre le paris malgré un épisode
neigeux qui nous donne aux uns et aux
autres
l'occasion de saluer le travail des
fonctionnaires et je saisis cette
opportunité pour rappeler notre
attachement à la fois un service public
et aux fonctionnaires et c'est justement
parce que nous sommes attachés aux
services publics et aux fonctionnaires
que mono nous menons une réforme de
transformation public nous allons
effectivement donné aux employeurs
publics plus de marge de manoeuvre plus
de liberté dans le choix de celles et
ceux qu'ils recrutent pour mener à bien
ses missions en permettant d'élargir les
conditions dans lesquelles nous pouvons
reconnaître est recruté par dont des
contractuels sans remettre en cause le
principe général de l'occupation des
emplois permanents par des agents
titulaires
cette nuit nous avons manqué de
fonctionnaires d'état nous avons manqué
de fonctionnaires départementaux
c'est cela la réalité qui s'est passé
cette nuit finalement avec votre réforme
vous voulez faire une fonction publique
sans fonctionnaires quand vous comme
vous voulez faire une fonction du
parlement sans parlementaire
[Musique]